We now set out to study
the Poisson process, which
is a continuous time version
of the Bernoulli process.
In the Bernoulli process,
time is divided into slots.
And during each
one of the slots,
we may either have an
arrival or no arrival.
In the Poisson process,
time is continuous.
And we may get
arrivals at any time.
We want to define
the Poisson process
by introducing some assumptions
that in some ways parallel
the assumptions that we made
for the Bernoulli process.
What where those assumptions?
The first one we made was the
assumption of independence--
namely that what happens
in different slots
are independent.
Similarly, for the
Poisson process,
we will make the following
independence assumption.
If we consider two intervals,
two time intervals that
are disjoint, and look at
the random variable that
stands for the
number of arrivals
during this interval
and that interval,
we will assume that these
two random variables
are independent.
But even more than
that, if we take
any collection of
disjoint time intervals,
and we look at the
associated random variables,
the associated
numbers of arrivals,
that collection
will also consist
of independent random variables.
The second assumption for
the Bernoulli processes
was one of time homogeneity,
namely at each slot,
we had the same
probability of an arrival.
We want to make a similar
assumption for the Poisson
process, and it's going
to be the following.
The probability that
we have k arrivals
during an interval of
a certain duration tau
is going to be the
same no matter where
that interval sits.
So if this is an interval
that has a certain duration,
and this is an interval
that has the same duration,
the probability of three
arrivals in this interval
is going to be the same as
the probability of three
arrivals in that interval.
And therefore, since
this probability does not
depend on where
the interval sits,
that probability
will be fully defined
by the number of arrivals
that we're interested in
and the length of
the interval as
opposed to the location
of the interval.
So we will be using
this notation here
to indicate this probability.
In this notation, we think
of tau as a constant.
And then, P of k corresponds
to probabilities.
In particular, if
you add over all k's
the various probabilities,
what you should get
would be a value
of 1, because this
exhausts all the possibilities.
And k here ranges
from 0 to infinity,
because we allow an arbitrarily
large number of arrivals
during a given time interval.
Now, with this
assumption in place,
it would still be
possible to have
arrivals that happen
simultaneously,
multiple arrivals at
the same time point.
In order to avoid
this situation,
we introduce one more assumption
which is the following.
It talks about the
number of arrivals
during a time interval that
has a small length delta.
During a small time
interval, there
is negligible probability of
having more than one arrival.
We will either have
one or zero arrivals.
And the probability
of one arrival
is a certain number,
lambda times delta.
It's proportional to delta.
So if the interval becomes
smaller and smaller,
that probability also goes to 0.
But it goes to 0 at a rate
proportional to delta.
So you can think of lambda
as probability per unit time.
These are the units of lambda.
Now here, I'm writing
an approximate equality.
What does that mean?
It means that these are
not exact expressions.
But they are exact within
a second order term.
And a second order
term is a term
that's negligible compared
to the first order term
when delta is small.
More precisely,
mathematically, what we mean
is that a second order term
compared to a first order term
goes to 0 as delta goes to 0.
Finally, let me
reiterate that lambda
should be interpreted
as an arrival rate.
It is a probability
per unit time.
The bigger lambda is, the
bigger the probability
is that we get an arrival
during a small time interval.
If we double lambda, then
we double the probability
that we have an arrival
during a small time interval.
And so we expect to have about
twice as many arrivals, hence
the interpretation
as an arrival rate.
We will see shortly that
this is also justified
because lambda shows up in
expressions for the expected
number of arrivals
during a time interval.